[Music]
I'm sorry I apologize I know she's ugly
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I
know I know I know it's Hillary Clinton
I apologize
so here's a little setup and she's on
the morning Joe the guy who had a dead
intern in his office
uh yes that guy I don't want to confuse
him with the other morning Joe's oh no
morning Mo that's lemon show I get him
confused morning
[Laughter]
all right now uh for something
completely different uh earlier this
month Gussy a new docu-series produced
by you and your daughter Chelsea
premiered on Apple TV plus
I'm sorry please pause sure you're
you're a [ __ ] idiot by the way I
sorry I just saw
the [ __ ] video that you posted to our
YouTube channel to announce oh yeah you
like it and in the spot for me it's just
Ryback eating chips you got a thank
Pepsi for that one that was his idea
that's [ __ ] hilarious
that's great and it's a gift of him
eating it and he's chroma keyed out
it's so stupid I'm sorry no no it just
that just popped up in the background
I'm like hey [ __ ] because it it was
jarring because I know what our
thumbnail is I'm like wait what the [ __ ]
all right sorry no you're good you're
good oh uh for something completely
different uh earlier this month gutsy a
new docu-series produced by you and your
daughter Chelsea premiered on Apple TV
I'd rather watch a documentary about
goatse
plus and in it you have these intimate
conversations with women of all
backgrounds and professions and you put
yourselves in their shoes it's really
fun in the first episode you discuss the
power of humor and one woman who was
very important to both of us who was
never hey Hillary explain humor to me
like I'm four
afraid to throw a proverbial punch take
a look
you know who I think has made great use
of humor on her work at the highest
levels you know very well is former
secretary Madeleine Albright because
when you think of the greats right like
the greats like the comics like you
think of prior
[ __ ] Carla Norm Macdonald yeah
exactly Norm Macdonald and you think
Legends of Comedy yeah and then
Madeleine Albright and metal well yeah I
mean she was a [ __ ] she was right she
was a stitch that woman she mastered the
art uh literally speaking and making
points often humorous ones with the pins
that she wore
okay so I I
play that real quick because
well
they're trying to sell you this show
as if it's
you know
real serious you know how Hillary's out
there the loser is out there
just meeting people of the world meeting
every day people like really like you
know like you know what you guys had me
wrong you could have had me but you
chose Trump so of course she interviewed
Megan to stallion so he'll hear me out
meow
give her a chance because maybe Megan
Italian isn't a dumb idiot like we all
think she is I can I just say this about
Megan the stallion sure
she did over a little bit of time become
a pretty good rapper like she didn't
even start off as a rapper when she came
out rapping it was like oh God here we
go she's actually become surprisingly
good and I'm just trying to give a
little compliment before we bury this
woman are you ready let's go let's go
this is like the best picture ever
whether she's rapping or going back to
school to get her bachelor's degree in
Health Administration she's like yes
he's like of course you all are
surrounding look at me I'm poor she is
proving by the way King what a [ __ ]
nerd this one is she couldn't even say
y'all she goes of course you all are
surrounding me
possible for women artists When You're
Not Afraid
look how not afraid they are this is
Hillary Clinton's show by the way I just
want to remind everybody you are
watching Hillary Clinton's show
it's almost like you could walk up and
grab their [ __ ] and they don't even
care
I wouldn't say that sir you get in
trouble I said almost almost
she certainly isn't bowed by the hate
that she receives and she's
unfortunately receives a lot of hate
uses it to fuel her creativity where
does she get a lot of hate oh my God
thank you I was about to say that I know
artists that get hate making the
stallion at least for for the people
that listen to this music
who hates her but I know people that
don't even really listen to rap that
don't find her particularly the worst
offender yeah you know what I mean like
I know it's like these other rappers I
see people going on like this [ __ ] at
least uh can make couple songs that are
like she does actually make some songs
that are fun so it's like I don't know
anybody it's like [ __ ] Megan yeah yeah
but that's that's exactly my point like
I mean
you know like I know people that hate
little Nas X you know like and I get why
by the way but I'm just you know I I've
never heard like oh my god making the
stallion is a Brendan shop of rap
and I think that it perversely gives her
a lot of energy yeah she's Unapologetic
Unapologetic
by the way Unapologetic hilarious
God damn it mush come on just saying
black women aren't normally known as
being machine guns of apologies
cranking out apologies why would you say
something so controversial yet so brave
[Music]
covet has definitely been a creative
time for me I've gotten back into
painting it makes me calm and I was
trying to please everybody and make
everybody else happy I was losing myself
I felt like so I just had to remember
who your Art's important
I was and I had to start spending a
little bit more time by myself to just
you know get back into me and figure out
what makes me happy
I loved money
art as a kid I was not good my parents
would come to a little like art show and
the teachers would invariably say
something like we really appreciate
Chelsea she keeps her workstation very
no no yeah you're absolutely right 100
you know you must have been really hard
you know coming up I love I love
somebody who's the [ __ ] who's always
been like the daughter of somebody
powerful being like Oh my God back in my
art school the private art school that I
went to
everyone was so friendly to me because
my dad was the president
very clean she's just so tidy apparently
she is very punctual one thing about her
she's on time she's on time okay all
right yeah and for the record because I
want to correct somebody in the chat
um sure somebody said she got she got
all of the worst of Bill and Hillary to
be fair she got all of the worst of
Hillary and web Hubble yes that's
correct yeah I can say that because
we're on Rumble I thought it was a
matter of record
I can say that
because we're on Rumble that one's from
my neck that felt good that was from my
[ __ ] Ken Starr R.I.P Ken
I'm sorry but bro
I'm gonna pop it in Show links so that
you know I'm not [ __ ] playing around
this is not a joke okay
um
I just posted it now you wanna you wanna
see a nice little comparison sure we're
reaching critical based
we're on [ __ ] Rumble who cares
oh God you're right
holy [ __ ]
yeah she looks like a young hag Raven
hate those things by the way she looks
like fighting those things she knows
she's looking pain in the ass she looks
like a god of war harpy
Kelsey follows rap music I think she has
ever since she was a little girl
but I kind of came to awareness of you
with the cuts in this conversation are
so incredibly jarring wait wait wait
wait wait till you see how she came will
be chemical think about her she's on
time she's on time she's great all right
yeah
Chelsea follows rap music she has
ever since she was a little girl
but I kind of came to awareness of you
with the cardi B WAP
why
why are we doing this
the lap a day in your life you all
[Laughter]
well she did with webhubble that's true
[Laughter]
virgie's really enjoying the web model
reference
that's so [ __ ] beast
I've always wanted to do a slime with
party as soon as she sent me the song I
think I sent it back to her like the
next day and it was just so exciting the
men they seem so confident in what
they're saying and they don't have no
problem with talking about their
sexuality and how they gonna have sex
with you okay no one I'm sorry did you
think rap was controversial you're not
the first sorry you're not the first hoe
to make a song about her [ __ ] I'm so
sorry to break it to you you know there
have been ones before you right like Lil
Kim Foxy Brown oh my god there have been
a ton uh uh Trina
yeah the baddest [ __ ]
thank you
the first ones to ever rap about their
[ __ ] I'm like this shit's been going
on since the 90s yeah
I'd also like to point out that biggie
is all y'all bitch's Grandpa cause he's
the one who got a little Kim to stop
[ __ ] being all gangster rap and [ __ ]
that's true the entire genre of music
was invented by Biggie on a whim he was
bored
so I was like well I could do that and
it's gonna Sound fire coming from a
woman is it great to see by the way it's
a good song women be so kind of fierce
it's actually that is the worst cardi B
and the worst Megan the stallion song
which is kind of funny but it's but it's
the one they're most known for
I can't even lie it's a beat on WAP goes
hard yeah I'm sorry look I always I
don't want I mean look I do not I have
to be honest with this stuff right it is
a good beat life's mission to make sure
that I'm always unapologetically me like
sometimes it's okay to apologize though
you know and I know you people are
Unapologetic I I've been to a movie
theater before so I get it but come on
man no matter what anybody says or how
they act towards me I don't ever want it
to shift what I think about myself I
don't care you know I was always like
this and it's just that you think
Hillary is happy that she could have
been the president right now but instead
she's doing interviews with Megan to
stallion
for apple plus
for apple plus exclusive show
people watching were you surprised
though by the conservative backlash to
you
there it is Ben Shapiro
but
Ben Shapiro there wasn't
a huge backlash he very comedically
read the lyrics
I don't when did he
what did he ever really try to cancel
you or anything or did he just like like
I love this when they go this backlab to
me a backlash means we're gonna cancel
this [ __ ] we're gonna ruin her [ __ ]
life not just people coming out and
going ah you know as a father I kind of
disagree with the messages
it's not it's not for me
that's what he basically did it and if
he really had a problem with it he
wouldn't have read the lyrics to comedic
effect on his show at first don't make
me defend Ben Shapiro
seriously I would rather defend making a
stallion do not
conservative backlash bro Hillary you
call black people super Predators what
the [ __ ] bro read the room
your husband's crime bill is why people
went to jail for 20 years for smoking a
blunt in some places get that for real
I was surprised that in this day and
time that when you have so many options
of so many things to look at and listen
to that the first thing that you want to
critique and talk about is something you
don't like that's like your one where
you've got the guy taking on the set
they get on the set and they're [ __ ]
uh this [ __ ] producers filling uh the
clintons in on [ __ ] on on home [ __ ]
because they actually don't know who
this person is they don't give a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] Hillary's only question is
so like when do I pull my hot sauce out
like oh my God
the whole time
she's waiting for the hot sauce she's
waiting she's waiting can I have a meal
with the black one so I could show them
my hot sauce
because you don't need the hot sauce
Hillary God damn no no Megan the
stallion she started giving Megan a
[ __ ] drink order
hey guys she's like you know what I'll
have a vodka uh vodka rocks please and
uh you know let me start off with
something light to eat you know like
it's Megan and the other thing is then
we have a vodka rocks and throw some
aren't you sitting there it's 9 A.M yeah
come on
a little something I don't want to get
scurvy looks like he's oh good Hillary
is now talking about thought [ __ ] just
this hold on guys the person who wanted
to be president
is that extra excerpt of the song
thought [ __ ] some kind of elected
official watching on his uh computer get
it Cheeto man
yep yeah stupid none of us I was never
listen
let me explain something to you just
because some dumb Boomers talk about
like that's not from that's no most
conservatives probably [ __ ] comes on know
the words too you know that like it's
just a famous song this whole like all
conservatives are so me shut up
aggressive [ __ ] you men that get
online bashing making Italians music
making the stallions music
not my music I have a lot to say about
things that you say you're not impressed
by and that you say you don't like so
somebody well for [ __ ] you first off we
all women do is talk about [ __ ] that
they say they don't care about
no who thinks it's terrible you sure
have uh that's like that that hope
[ __ ] irritates me dude [ __ ] an AP
will harp on that [ __ ] too [ __ ] like
no I just don't like it it's not that
[ __ ] I secretly like it it's not like
[ __ ] I I hate that stupid [ __ ] dude
oh you don't like gay people what are
you gay yeah exactly [ __ ] just
it's such a shitty and I keep saying and
I keep saying yes I am why don't you
believe me
I've been so clear
it's the lyrics right they dissect the
lyrics they dissect my life well let me
give y'all something y'all might
actually want to see
so I'm like okay boo
I want to see your titties right now can
you make that happen can we see your
titties
they're on the internet right make it
it's time to see it's got to be out
there right I'm looking she looks She's
what but first off hold on Pepsi Pepsi
how did you know so fast cardi B yes
Nicki Mina because I I like like you
know how merch loves cardi B like this
is mine I I I I love me oh I love making
the stallion too don't get me wrong I
mean all right
but no she's a good girl
he says
[Music]
watching me go through it's gonna drag
me I think they secretly that's actually
one of her better songs no Virgie you
heard it I think they secretly like it
you too yeah I feel like they're the
majority of the views okay so then using
that tactic and I think that Hillary
wants to [ __ ] Trump I think she secretly
wants to [ __ ] him
I think she wants to [ __ ] him for real
though maybe what are the kind of
craziest things people have said about
you people say well they called me girl
and
Cricket mostly
mostly
a lot of crazy stuff yes they do and I'm
trying to keep it as PG as I can once I
read the woman the woman who did wet ass
[ __ ] is trying to keep it as PG as she
can guys think my life well let me give
y'all something y'all maybe actually one
just becomes a juice
the next morning
[Laughter]
this is the truth my husband and I got
married before we got married oh I'm
married everybody oh you're married oh
yeah I'm married all the time I've also
been divorced yeah wife because you're
such a lovely person
imagine being married to a [ __ ]
Clinton
Jesus Christ
I didn't either and then when you
respond it's like oh you're supposed to
be above it you're supposed to be this
and that and I'm like girl I'm a human
too
like you know what I don't care I don't
want you to be above it I please get
down in the dirt it's more fun anyway
right I actually really don't care you
could I really don't they've been
talking about this for five minutes guys
but she doesn't even care bro
[ __ ] haters boo
I'm trying to do a an Opie making the
stallion
sweet bizarre haters
eaters man
I don't even care about this probably
have said the worst thing you could ever
said to me and you just went about your
day you ate your sandwiches you went to
work yeah I get it but why are you
dressed like guile from the Street
Fighter movie you need to know we can
all go home we can't go home
work like you
hung out with you she's dressed like
she's like gonna be walking around with
a baguette in France you know
Emily you forgot you said it and then
I'm carrying it around all day so I'm
like okay I definitely can't be carrying
this baggage have you tried to limit how
much
have you tried to limit how black you
act sorry old habits old habits I'm so
sorry old habits old habits have you
tried not being so super predatory
sorry preded uh I could say with an a
right right right right honey it just
keeps looking at her right honey
what am I allowed to say
do we still call them Negroes now you
notice there's not around these people
ever Bill no Bill's making a vlog like
Opie at the beach house yeah cool do
whatever you want
I don't have to go do I no no I have fun
with that all right later
you're watching football or sweatpants
yeah all you hear is like all right bye
then you're here
simple
I love Friday shows only online I have
to take a break from social media I
think you're smart yeah I really wanted
to work on some new music and actually
write and get [ __ ] wow women quit
social media talks about it what a
[ __ ] breakthrough
how long did you quit one day maybe a
week she's probably tweeting right now
bro okay because when you like let a lot
of outside noise in it kind of like
stops you from your like your original
Mission and I feel like that's what okay
I'm sorry Megan I haven't asked a
question like I knew what Gandhi's
mission was Martin Luther King's mission
was like
Megan what's your mission I gotta be
honest what's your mission her mission
is to be on her thought [ __ ] and get
shot by Tory Lanez in the foot
okay well you know what hey you gave me
an answer that's more than other people
can yeah
what's happening
cardi B and Megan Italian just set the
entire female gender back 100 years with
the disgusting and wild side yeah okay
but but that's just an opinion right
that's just like your opinion man
how this isn't like a campaign again
like you notice there was none of this
like
D platformer or take her down that's
just a woman who's probably a mom going
yeah this is pretty gross
that's a pretty I mean look and you can
make the argument of like you keep
wanting to be empowered but then you
make [ __ ] like this it's like it's like
the Patrice goes Joe's like I gave you I
gave you a chance to be something more
but you you you're the one that
categorized yourself as a series of
holes and that's they do it to
themselves it's like look I get it I
look I don't give a [ __ ] let me be clear
here what ass [ __ ] does not bother me
as a matter of fact I kind of like it
like I said but
if you're asking me to take a step back
and understand why people think it's a
hypocritical yeah I get why people think
it's hypocritical I could see that
argument being made you know
[Music]
you see a lot of people hey you think a
lot of people are watching Hillary's
Apple TV show
I don't think a lot of people are
watching Apple TV no no so no how many
uh Emmys did they win
Apple TV you saw the Emmys right HBO
just [ __ ] took every Emmy yeah bro I
know that was [ __ ] and you know what
dude Kim Wexler didn't get one she
should have [ __ ] got one like the
chick who plays her anyway uh what's her
name
pessie you're [ __ ] what's her name
Maria seahorn I knew it I [ __ ] knew
he knew her name but attacking a woman
right and then it's like the first thing
they think is less bandwagon on it I
also heard this I also know that unless
disregard how this may be making her
feel right now look at her having a
breakdown like you know what I'm saying
like you put me through so much and then
when I finally start responding now I'm
crazy now I'm having a mental breakdown
it's always yeah but it's like you were
seeing like really mental breakdown kind
of [ __ ] bro it's the same Playbook
though right but I had to really just
learn that that's what comes with being
a power of a woman
when you don't show any weakness they
try to keep on figuring out what what is
it that's going to make her tick as much
as you come at me
I'm gonna come at you I'm gonna be but
I'm gonna come at you just with my
confidence right you hear that you hear
that merch nice try
she's not putting up with Annie and as
much as you come at her she's coming at
you bro yeah she uh I would I would say
this she takes no Guff and I don't mean
to use that kind of language what is
Rumble all out cause it's Rumble but
don't do it on a YouTube show she takes
no golf don't say the g word
hey Royce go back like like five seconds
just go back five seconds okay now I'm
crazy now I'm having there so no there's
this there you can
Hillary's starting to do this thing in
the conversation where she's trying to
use her hands like Megan oh yeah yeah
yeah here I got you here it's not
working stuff
I see what you're saying I'm trying to
keep it as PG as I can once I read that
I wasn't really in school and I'm doing
it for clout first it was no but yeah I
didn't either and then when you respond
it's like oh you're supposed to be above
it you're supposed to be this and that
and I'm like girl I'm a human too
like you know what I actually really
don't care you could probably have said
the worst thing you could have ever said
to me and you just went about your day
you ate your sandwiches you went to work
like you
hung out with your family you ate your
sandwiches is she hungry like why would
that she just brought that up several
she keeps bringing up why did you keep
bringing up sandwiches they wanted to
work on some new music and and actually
right y'all we got some sandwiches back
there because I'm [ __ ] fresh out
you put me through so much and then when
I finally started responding now I'm
crazy now I'm having a mental breakdown
it's always the same Playbook though
right but I had to really just learn
that that's what comes with being a
powerful woman when you don't show any
weakness they try to keep on figuring
out what what is it that's going to make
them as much as you come at me I'ma come
at you I'm gonna be but I'm gonna come
at you girlfriend
you girlfriend
talk to the hand girl should I take my
hot sauce out now
honey honey should I take my hot sauce
mom you didn't bring the [ __ ] hot
sauce again you just bring the [ __ ]
control yourself do not take that hot
sauce it's an even fancy Mom it's
Tabasco it's not even know what if they
bring the sandwiches you don't have to
just eat it without the hot sauce
this is why you lost this is why you
lost because of [ __ ] like this because
having a handbag full of [ __ ] hot
sauce
so right it's also killing people I mean
you were just my life maybe one day
you'll get tired I don't know but you're
not gonna break me down yeah I bet you
get worn out before I do I doubt it
actually depending on what circumstances
we're discussing yeah worn out which way
I'm sure there's a scenario I could
think of uh Megan where I would get worn
out before you
there's one situation
also she's a terrible painter you've got
a stormy night look at her store
Clinton's Army night oh whoa you're so
tidy
[Music]
okay so that was the Megan Italian style
oh my God this is her fajitas yes yes
yes this is her eating normal human food
outside are we eating pools if she pulls
some hot sauce out of her purse I will
[ __ ] die bro I'll kill myself
dude they keep you know what I wonder if
this is a prank because they keep
testing her to see if she'll blogs on
Town that's why they keep doing the show
is just set up yeah see if she'll ever
pull the hot sauce out
you're getting
a face ew I don't want to think of her
getting a facial yeah no thank you
truly unbelievable humor can be a
powerful antidote even when it comes to
taking on things like Prejudice
[ __ ] what did you just say
he said whatever the [ __ ] script said
to say
and it was profoundly stupid she's one
of the dumbest people that's ever lived
bro
you're an activist and a comic oh trust
me I Can Tell She's an activist bro that
is
one of the most aggressively Jewish
looking people I've ever seen
Kenneth looks like like an anti-Semitic
like caricature she looks like mortman's
wife and Family Guy yes
a little of your background I wanted to
be in public service and I wanted to
make a difference and all that stuff and
I realized that was like hard work but
um the pool of Comedy was just too
comedy are you really funny
um so at a certain point I went you know
into being full-time
um in comedy and what did your parents
say I mean my immigrant parents
immigrated from why did you have to say
that hold on look at her face yeah first
off my immigrant parent who says that if
I asked you first just ask just ask me
like anything about my parents anything
any normal question
yeah so um tell me a little bit about
your parents okay so listen my immigrant
parents who came here because they're
immigrants from another country what was
the question you need you need to start
referring to them as that I would like
to like
in every circumstance like when you go
out to dinner my immigrant parents will
have a steak
my immigrant mother will have a some
wine
excuse me waiter um so my immigrant
parents are celebrating their
anniversary this week um I'd like to get
them a nice bottle of wine please
they're immigrants though just make sure
you know that make sure it's you know
good wine
oh [ __ ] loved it
wow okay but hear me out Chelsea
Clinton's really ugly I remember what
the feeling that my parents were
disappointed in me because I overheard
my mom saying to one of her friends I'm
disappointed in the game
it's my kind of Comedy that keeps Isis
going
look racist no the US government
bombing little brown children
well I don't know we sure are we sure
this woman isn't the US government if I
closed my eyes and pictured the US
government like as a person if you had
to draw a caricature if you went to one
of the boardwalk artists and tell them
to do a caricature of the US government
they draw her
can you draw a post-modern America if it
was a person
Isis is training right now to kill your
whole family and [ __ ] down your neck
hole after they remove your head with a
dull blade can I invite you to a
stand-up comedy show it's called the
Muslims are coming funny guys she uses
profanities wait the Muslims are coming
is she Muslim
oh she might not be Jewish bro she might
be Muslim there's a bunch of Muslims on
stage but they're hilarious yep okay
I mean unless unless she's from
Palestine scary as a death threat I've
ever gotten was actually to my parents
home phone and we you know we're gonna
kill your daughter and we're gonna kill
all of you if she keeps doing what she's
doing and that's how I met Hillary she
was the one on the call and she goes oh
my God wrong number
dude and that's how we became close
friends yes she was calling to threaten
another person is it different oh it was
one she meant to call one of our lawyers
and that we've we've been best of
friends ever since I said wait a minute
uh what what are you trying to reach
foreign
y everybody who's famous gets weird
threats and stuff like I just like the
fact that if somebody like tries to kind
of pivot into being an activist and said
then they could turn all those threats
into like a crusade Isis is trying to
kill me that's probably just some prank
call or [ __ ] with you did you say
Crusade because she's Muslim
[Laughter]
we got a donation here cheers fellas
Thank You Sage [ __ ] much appreciated
again remind you is telling jokes
so one of the films I made you know the
only reason I'm still watching is I'm
waiting to see if she puts hot sauce on
anything called the Muslims are coming
um which you know some people thought
was like a like oh this sucks she made
her whole identity about people hating
Muslims so nobody cares about Muslims
anymore
oh no her entire set was written for an
audience in 2007 yes specifically it
doesn't work in any other way the shock
value of like oh I'm Muslim now you
basically only works on like Laura
Loomer yeah it's very funny
[ __ ] Laura Boomer
um